eso fue todo lo que duró el discurso de
manuel marco un discurso muy esperado
tras dos días de reuniones con las
diferentes formaciones políticas de la
asamblea nacional todo esto con el
objetivo de obtener una mayoría absoluta
y poder gobernar el presidente dijo que
había escuchado el mensaje que le
enviaron los franceses tras este voto en
las legislativas del pasado domingo que
se trata de un país que está fracturado
de un país donde hay muchas divisiones y
que todo esto llama a una
responsabilidad y es la de saber
gobernar la de saber legislar de una
manera distinta sabe muy bien que una
parte de la responsabilidad de la
mayoría presidencial es finalmente la de
ampliar se descartó por ahora la idea de
un gobierno de unión nacional dijo que
esto por ahora no se justificaba pero
como ampliar esa mayoría ya sea una
coalición o la otra opción es
simplemente mayoría según los diferentes
textos de ley que vayan a agotarse ahora
el presidente dejó la responsabilidad en
manos de las formaciones o políticas son
ellas las que tienen que decir hasta qué
punto están dispuestas a llegar para
cooperar para que el país pueda ser
gobernado pueda gobernarse no haya una
crisis institucional y en todo caso dijo
que esperaba conocer la respuesta de las
diferentes formaciones o políticas a su
regreso porque el presidente va a
ausentarse durante varios días a partir
de este jueves por compromisos
internacionales e hizo ahínco también en
que en realidad pues hay varios
proyectos de ley varios textos que hay
que votar dentro de las próximas semanas
que los franceses están esperando son
textos urgentes que tienen que ver con
la salud el clima el pleno empleo y
sobre todo el poder adquisitivo